[Music]
Okay, thank you for joining us today. Uh
we are going to talk about why we called
the Gajimaru the Gajimaru. And to that
end, I should just pass straight to
Craig. Uh Craig is sitting in Okinawa,
Japan. And uh actually the inspiration
comes from there. So over to you, Craig.
Looking at making a a blockchain that
actually works. Um we had a great base
to start from with a lot of the issues
but there were lots of outstanding ones.
One of them is scalability and we knew
that at the root of it you have to do
what the traditional banking system done
to some degree which is partition the
problem and try to get down as local as
possible whenever needed. So have that
as an option and that winds up looking
at as a tree structure. And as when I
was first trying to write this out I
didn't know what to call it. Um,
and I guess fortuitously outside of my
office window there is a type of tree
that's got
uh they called a gajimaru and it's got a
single it it grows first from a single
bowl but pretty quickly it starts
dropping these support roots and they
wind up becoming trunks of their own
which is similar to the structure that
we actually want. uh we would like to
have you know branch connections between
different tree trunks that all are
themselves independent trees. Um the
thing to tie them together uh that you
can't do without if you want to make a
digital currency is you have to have an
anonymous uh proofof work mint to to
define the currency itself. Uh and a
mint that no party can control which
means that we can trust it. So a trust
dispense required that requires proof of
work for a whole bunch of reasons we
can't go into right now but it's an
important thing but then we that
consensus model doesn't work for
everything. So we want to be able to
have this freedom to create other chains
that have their own rules but all who
can speak the same language and use this
single currency across across all the
chains. Um so anyway seeing this tree I
was like oh hey that's a good working
name. It's a crazy name. It'll be easy
to search for later. Gajimaru and we use
that name and then it stuck and so
that's so that's what we're going with.
It's the Gajimaru. Um as far as how the
chains talk to each other, how the
interplay works, uh Dimitar knows the
details. He's been working on helping
implement a lot of that. So could you
mention some
of those uh different trees that uh Greg
was talking about those we call
associate chains and they're all spawn
from the from the mint and they share
the same economy uh but uh they can vary
in their approach of what is allowed
there and what is not. uh they can have
different consensus uh so they can be
using not proof of work proof of stake
proof of authority and whatever is
suitable for the particular business
case that they're solving. Uh what this
allows is uh for them to have their own
independent database
uh their own independent uh CPU space.
So basically their own transaction to
uh this means that if there is a really
big uh transaction flow from business A
uh that is running on one associate
chain this is not going to impact
different associate chain and their
throughut uh something that uh we have
seen times and times again when there is
a really viral product on let's say
Ethereum uh the whole network is
congested and uh this hurts the business
case for everyone else that is trying to
do anything. And this drives the fees up
uh because everyone is trying to keep
bribing miners or block producers to be
including their transaction instead of
the other transactions that are
currently in the pool. uh with the
Soc is not a problem because you as a
business uh can own your own transaction
throughput and it doesn't interfere with
anyone else's and uh depending on what
your expectations of the transactions
you expect on your chain would be. uh
you can define your own block size uh
costs and you can even for allow new
functionalities depending what you
actually need
uh and how this ties to the whole
ecosystem. Uh I'll pass the boat to so
he can explain. The thing that really
makes this sets this apart from just a
loose collection of chains um is like
dim said that we provide uh a whole
ecosystem. So the things that we will um
demand in the gajuaru is that when you
have an account that account is valid on
every chain um and each associate chain
will treat the main chain the mint uh
kind of like uh a local bank would treat
the central bank. That's where you get
the the mint actually produces the coin
for the entire ecosystem. The coin is
valid on all associate chains. So when
you start an associate chain, you will
essentially check out gaju maru which is
then or gajus which are then transferred
from the mint uh to your associate chain
and then you can work it uh actually use
actual money on your associate chain and
the gadu can be transferred between
associate
chains and
um and you as a user can transfer gajus
from your account on one associate chain
to your account on another associate
chain. And uh it's important for this
also to for the mint to be a
fullyfledged uh
highcapacity
trustless blockchain. Um so that you can
you can essentially you could run your
applications on the gajubaru in the
unregulated space. Uh and then for
performance reasons if you are
successful
um you may actually want to spawn an
associate chain and move your traffic
out there. uh or if you decide that you
actually need to become real and adapt
to the jurisdiction your business
operates in, you can also move to an
associate chain and adapt consensus
uh KYC whatever to your local legal
needs and still be part of this
ecosystem. And uh essentially then you
would probably treat the gajus as more
or less foreign currency that's not
under your regulatory control but you
can still use it. When people talk about
uh a lot of these things in blockchain
the assumption is that there is a one
ring to rule them all type approach and
and as we've discussed before people
miss the fact that JR Tolken is really
talking about how that is an absolute
power that absolutely corrupts. Um but
there's a more fundamental point that
you're hitting on here which is that
there is no one solution for every need
or requirement. And when you start
looking at something like for example
how might we implement blockchain as a
payments rails for banks to operate
within a country. So you gave the
example of a central bank and large
banks but actually for certain types of
transactions you're going to want
certain levels of of security and
participation. for others you might want
something else. And there was a central
bank we were talking to in the past and
that was exactly one of the points they
made is that if someone's buying a
coffee, we're quite happy for the cost
of that coffee transaction to be
reflected in a very high-speed chain
that operates a certain way. Uh but we'd
really like something very secure for
interbank settlements, end of day
settlements and so on. And this is
exactly what we need to appreciate that
in the real world there are different
needs and requirements around how a
blockchain itself would be implemented
and used. And the fact that the Gajimaru
itself lends itself to this whole idea
that it says okay well you need a core
that works but then you can begin to
compose all of these associate chains
around it that are their own blockchain
effectively and can choose their
consensus method. can can choose how
they want to operate but do that with
the security of the Gaju underpinning it
and the Gajimaru Mint itself.
[Music]